a lot of companies are putting out the
old help wanted sign as tourism comes
back
so could be a rush for applications
could be rushed for interviews and our
bianca holmen
well she's live at the goodwill career
center they have one at the boulevard
mall and bianca's got tips
and tricks for job seekers hi bianca
hey good morning good morning everybody
out there you know we're used to seeing
this side of the
goodwill facility here at the boulevard
mall but you know what
there's the career services unit that's
right here in the store
and come on inside come on inside this
is where you'll be greeted and met by
folks ready to help you to get back to
work i'm joined here by
karen uh marvin so tell us the job
market
impacted greatly by the pandemic what
are you all now seeing
as people are getting back to work so
we're hearing a lot about the
hospitality jobs that are coming back
but during the pandemic we actually saw
some job sectors increase so commercial
driving license cdl and logistics
health care and technology and some of
those are really pandemic proof
and so when folks come into the career
center our career coaches will make sure
that they apply for jobs
that are going to be great for them for
a long sustained future
and what if you say you know what hey
i've been in hospitality for for
decades i don't have that training how
can you all fill those gaps
so we've got a couple of programs i'd
love for the viewers to know about where
we will actually help with training and
job experiences on the job training if
you will
for veterans and their spouses and we
have another grant in conjunction with
the city of henderson where
henderson residents can actually come in
and we'll work with them to figure out
what kind of job experience they want
and get them into the training and it's
all free yeah and this can be
overwhelming you know a lot of folks may
be sitting at home they were laid off
you know what they've been gone through
a lot maybe impacted by the covet
themselves or family members so
it's good to know that you all are here
and there's help in the community to
help you
also you got a job there coming up give
us those details we have a job fair
coming up here at the boulevard mall on
friday may
7th from 10 a.m to 1 p.m we will have
multiple employers here on site taking
resumes doing interviews
hopefully hiring on the spot wonderful
that's good to hear and again for folks
who maybe they got an interview coming
up what's one thing that you've been
seeing
that's a mistake that people are making
out there as they nail that interview
um practice it's really and when you
come into the career center our career
coaches will actually do mock interviews
with you
to kind of run through that so you can
get down your elevator pitch all right
sounds good perfect practice makes
perfect okay all right so again all
great information we're going to tweet
out this information it's going to be on
our website
but again we're looking to help you get
back to work as las vegas opens back up
going to send it back to you guys in the
studio